so thank you all for coming to share in
this momentous occasion
I would ask that members of the media
hold questions until after dr. Rothman
finishes his talk I'm Bob Alpern Dean of
Yale School of Medicine and I am pleased
to welcome you all here for this joyous
celebration so I will make a few brief
comments it's there there is a great
tradition at Yale in cell biology the it
was really started by Georg Pilate who
identified a number of key vesicular
structures within cells and using
electron microscopy was able to
determine what those vesicles did the
that tradition was passed on through a
number of great cell biologists a number
of great department chairs of the cell
biology and the most recent department
chair is our honoree today Jim Rothman
what Jim did many years ago is he had
this realization that to really
understand how these vesicles moved
around in the cell you had to get rid of
the cell and and you had to actually
study the vesicles isolated a lot of
people in those days thought that that
wasn't possible that the vesicles would
not function in a cell-free system Jim
had the courage to do it and the talent
to make it work and led to really a
molecular understanding of how vesicles
traffic through the cell that has
exploded today and so we are delighted
with the decision of the Nobel Committee
to award the prize to Jim today and it's
great to be here to celebrate it so let
me now introduce the president of Yale
University Peter salivate
thank you Bob thank you all for being
here today and congratulations Jim
we are just delighted and I have to
admit I personally am a little stunned
I'm not being inaugurated as yells
president until next weekend and I get
to have the incredible honor and good
fortune to introduce and celebrate with
you a Nobel laureate this week Jim
Rothman represents the best of Yale in
so many ways he's an esteemed professor
on our faculty and a summa [ __ ] laude
graduate of Yale College his Nobel Prize
confirms quite simply what we all knew
about him his preeminence in his field
really his fields of cell biology and of
chemistry where his pioneering and
innovative work and creative research
have really taught us how cells work and
more significantly the implications for
some of the most troublesome diseases
and conditions that affect humankind
you know Jim is a pioneer in many ways
on the West Campus Yale's West Campus
Jim's interdisciplinary nano biology
Institute was one of the first research
centers that we set up there it brings
together researchers in fields like cell
biology molecular biophysics and
biochemistry physiology engineering and
they're all working on nano machines
that can function within living cells
this activity also has implications for
combating disease for improving life and
health of people all over the world but
for all this spectacular research and
for all that Jim Rothman is being
honored for today in this Nobel Prize
for all that this represents as a
pinnacle moment in a scholar and
researchers career I have to tell you
what Jim Rothman is going to do after
this press conference he's he going to
go back to his lab and discover
something new and important
well eventually but night not not an
hour from now if he's gonna go back to
his office and bask in the
congratulations of his friends and of
his colleagues well he'll get to do that
too but not right after this press
conference rather he is going to go
teach not one but he's two classes this
afternoon and I think it is wonderful
and it is everything that we celebrate
in a Yale professor that after winning a
Nobel Prize after meeting all of you and
spending a little time with you that
Professor Rothman will head to class to
share his knowledge with Yale students
and who knows in his class might be a
future Nobel Prize winner as well well
for now it's with great pride with great
joy with the best wishes of the entire
Yale community that we celebrate this
moment and I introduced to you James
Rothman the Fergus F Wallace professor
of cell biology professor of chemistry
professor and chair of the department of
cell biology director of the Yale
nanobiology Institute and of course 2013
Nobel Prize laureate Jim Rothman
and
well this is absolutely overwhelming and
I thank Peter and and Bob for their
wonderful opening remarks and I'm so
it's so nice for me to see the people
many of the people from my laboratory
here actually and Department and thank
you for coming in and showing your
support now I'm not quite sure what the
format here is I guess I'm going to take
some questions maybe I could make a
brief statement or so at the very
beginning this is this is a great
University and this is a great country
and I've been very very fortunate to
have grown up and been educated in this
fine place and taught to appreciate
taught to appreciate science and
intellectual activity and it's at its
highest to have matured and started my
career as a researcher at a time when
your idea was the only limit any risk
could be taken no matter how how
difficult and and I was fortunate to
have taken a few of those risks and
today's Nobel Prize recognizes you know
I guess the success that that came out
of that it's a little still a little
hard to believe this is all happening I
have to admit and you know Bob Bob
mentioned that a little bit about the
process of protein trafficking in the
cell and I was reminded of the fact that
endorphins are secreted they're stored
in secretory what the theme of today's
one of the theme of today's Nobel Prize
is the organization of transport
pathways in the cell and and the storage
of secretory products and one of the
less Harold had been absolutely critical
secretory products are the endorphins
which cause a good mood now everybody
has commented on how my mood has been
very good today
and and and my my wife joy Hirsch and
has commented that I haven't yet
complained today and it's already 12:30
and I think that's because the secretory
pathway that my colleagues Randy
Schekman
Tom suit off and I are credited with
having understood in a new way has been
stimulated and so my endorphins are
stimulated my adrenaline however is not
yet stimulated I'm sure the questions
will allow that to happen
certainly my my dopamine has been
stimulated as a reward system but but
I'm counting on some good questions from
the press to overcome the lack of sleep
that came about from a call I received
at 4:30 a.m. this morning shortly after
that I called the Dean of the medical
school my boss dr. al pijn he was a
little grumpy he didn't pick up the
phone right away
but then I think something occurred to
him and he called me back
and his day has probably been about as
hectic as mine head so I want to I want
to thank all of you for coming and I
look forward to taking any questions
that any of you might might have could
you raise your hand so I can see I'm a
great believer in eye contact thank you
yeah it was I was asleep okay now in
past years I have not been asleep on
such occasions but the calls didn't
arrive as a result I gave up I went to
sleep very nicely and a friendly Swedish
voice began the conversation and
professor Hanson a young Geron Hanson
the Secretary of the Nobel Committee was
kind enough to inform me and I tried to
keep myself on the ground that I was a
recipient of this year's Nobel Prize and
he went on to tell me who I shared it
with and I expressed as I would like to
do right now make my my very strong
delight in sharing this prize with Randy
Schekman at the University of California
Berkeley and Tom Stewart off at Stanford
University Randy and I in particular go
back a very long way we shared a number
of awards together and we have we
started our projects which have been
complementary some would say competitive
many many years ago in the late 1970s
and I have found not only Professor
Schekman to be a great scientist but
we've always been very open and the kind
of openness in our although we've never
formally collaborated the openness and
the conveyance of information that we've
had we used to have actually joint
research group meetings in more recent
years as my work has entered more taking
on more of a tilt towards understanding
how the brain works I've become more
familiar with Professor suit off and
have found him to be not only a great
scientist but a wonderful collaborator
we wrote a review article together that
a few years ago for science magazine
that was a great pleasure
so that call was was another out-of-body
experience I could see that it was
happening
yes yes you've received a Nobel Prize
and all that I haven't quite there
jested yet to be honest if you if you
have any interest in the subject
tomorrow okay if something good in the
news doesn't come up come back and ask
me tomorrow yes sir ah well that's
that's a very good question you know I
was so fortunate to start out at a time
when it was possible for a young
scientist to have an idea take a risk to
seem to do the impossible I see dr.
Jameson there and that but the fourth or
fifth Road dr. Jamison and dr. Pilate in
in work that preceded mine discovered
really the the secrete secretory
pathways and a Jim you won't remember
this but I remember cornering you at a
meeting shortly after I started at
Stanford and I asked you I said I'm
thinking about reproducing what you've
done in a cell-free extract in the test
tube and you told me I was crazy okay
and you know he hired me back many years
later but anyway so the NIH was prepared
to support me coming from a good lab no
particular track record going to a good
lab a good department but but with no
preliminary data no nothing and I had
five years of failure really and before
I had the first initial sign of success
and I'd like to think that that kind of
support existed today but I think
there's less less of it and and it's a
it's it's actually becoming a pressing
national issue if not an international
issue I appreciate being asked that
question
other questions
okay well I'm supposed to be so I'm
gonna give that a try okay
and it's also a very very good question
the cells in the body need to
communicate with each other right if we
remote we're obviously very calm our
bodies are very complex and the
different parts of the body needs to be
in sync with each other and that
principle is very fundamental but each
cell has its own boundary or it wouldn't
be its own self your liver has a job
your brain has a job within the brain
there are many jobs that need to be done
this requires the the movement of
substances from one cell to another
probably everybody here is familiar with
one of the most well understood
substances of that kind insulin which as
you know is very important for
controlling blood sugar and when when it
when the meat when the metabolism were
production or biological handling of
insulin or response to it are altered
inappropriately we can get diabetes
whether it be juvenile diabetes or adult
diabetes so-called type-2 diabetes there
are many other substances in the body
neurotransmitters for example are stored
in little packets they're actually like
little balloons they're perhaps 500
hydrogen atoms in diameter that's how
small they are they are very tiny little
sacs but each one contains a very potent
quantity of neurotransmitters and those
neurotransmitters are released at just
the right time and within the brain at
the right place within the brain and the
right neural circuits so that we can
think and act and feel and when our
feelings become out of balance which can
happen in many forms of disease I'm
thinking about psychiatric disease
oftentimes this is the result of an
imbalance of neurotransmitters and we
treat these diseases perhaps a little
more bluntly than we would like someday
to be able to treat them with drugs that
modulate neurotransmitters prozac is a
perfect example okay neurodegenerative
diseases also require a provision of
neurotransmitter critical
neurotransmitters I
and Parkinson's disease is an example of
that so there are great many imbalances
in these pathways that I had I had a
free moment this morning to read what
the Nobel Committee wrote and in their
in their description they point out the
many many ways in which imbalances in
these secretory and transport pathways
are are very commonly found in diabetes
and in certain immunological disorders
and certainly in neurological disorders
and the fundamental understanding of
these pathways opens the way to assess
new drugs to better develop personalized
medicine based on a better molecular
understanding and therefore a better
prescription of the drugs that that we
have available today so I hope that at
least begins to answer your question ok
so that I don't know if everybody could
hear the question the question was how
did I hear about the award and and how
did it make me feel well I mean I heard
about it in a phone call that came at
4:30 a.m. from the the secretary of the
Nobel Committee and I have to say made
me feel awake and rather good rather
good thank you
well I wish there were a short answer to
that I'll try to give you one you know I
think the the real answer is there is
usually not one moment okay because the
work that was recognized today whether
it was the work that came from my
laboratory or the other two laureates
represented a cumulative effort of
research in depth in the topic that went
on for in my case 25 years in which I
certainly hope will continue I met with
my group today and I said hey guys it's
not over yet
okay you may think we can slack off but
no no no okay
but it seriously it's it's a these are
to address very profound questions in
nature these are complex questions no
there are certain high points along the
way that one can point to and there's
certainly an inspiration to get started
mine came actually when I was a
first-year medical student at Harvard
and when I was at Yale my background I
studied physics primarily in mathematics
and so I was oriented towards machinery
so to speak and a physical view of the
world and I was exposed as a medical
student for the first time - and some
limited understanding of the
complexities that occur within a cell
and in the way that a young doctor would
see it and actually I'll always remember
the lecture in histology we're actually
Jameson and Pilates work was being shown
it was very fresh then okay and I
thought my goodness
how could those vesicles form from that
membrane and know where to go and it was
a complete mystery how that could happen
at a molecular level and so when I had
the opportunity and was prepared to take
the risk that's what I decided to focus
on and it was really that inspiration
well in what we're spent well it's yeah
I think it's it's it's well under thank
you for asking that you know it's well
understood that the you know of course
right now
the entire federal budget is under
restriction because of sequester but and
I'm not referring to sequester here but
force that's bad enough but win7 before
sequester over the last especially five
to seven years the NIH budget which we
all rely on and has made America the
great engine of biomedical discovery and
also biomedical and medical innovation
not to mention the the generator of our
very important biotechnology and
pharmaceutical industries this this this
budget has not really grown appreciable
in fact in real terms and accounting for
inflation it's it's actually fallen
significantly I don't have the exact
number but I believe it's in double
digits and in addition to that there has
the NIH has adjusted the way that it
spends money or at least reviews money
and again I'm not an expert on this but
the end result of it is that a much
smaller percentage of the grant
applications are getting funded and it
really depends on what part of the NIH
and so on and frankly I don't have the
exact numbers so I can't be quoted on
them but it's much much more difficult
qualitatively more difficult for young
scientists to get started today whereas
we would expect a young scientist to be
on their own undertaking a risky project
within it with a within about a year of
their starting their labs maybe 10 or 15
years ago today if they're fortunate to
get an NIH grant it will take several
years three four years and the level of
funding that they receive is I believe
in
in in relative terms less then one might
have received certainly I received when
I why was I was started so I sometimes
on occasions like this when when I have
the occasion would have the opportunity
to reflect would I have been able to do
and initiate take the risk I really am
very concerned that I would not have
been and I don't mean to personalize
that because I'm just one example of
many people and and I see today the the
the kind of the enormous opportunities
and yet the discouragement that young
scientists in this country feel and it's
something that we do need to pay
attention to if we want to maintain this
country as the great competitive world
leader that it has been
I have a hard time giving such advice
today III would say
there's always room to be quite honest
there's always room for four for a
brilliant young people to be successful
but you really have to be prepared to
make a sacrifice to do that I'm hopeful
the situation will turn around but I
have to say I'm more measured I'm very
sad to say I'm more measured in my in my
my view of and I then I would have been
five years ago and I hope five years
from now as a result of honest
statements such as the one that I'm
making right now that there might be
some operator opportunity than there is
today sorry to pour cold water on a
great
but I should I should really finish that
by saying that I do have a lot of faith
in the United States of America this is
the greatest country in the world we
will if we all pay attention enough
attention to in an honest way we will
find a way through this crisis and and
and we have to thank you
once again we congratulate Jim Rothman
we thank you all for coming and you see
now the charmed life that the yell
president leads a member of our faculty
who is also an alumnus of Yale College
wins the Nobel Prize and our football
team is three I know thank you all for
coming